Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史就是这样》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我拼不对这个词。所以你随便给个假名字，比如你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在证人保护计划里。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改你的拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Oh, Jeeves, I said. About that Czech suit. Yes, sir? Is it really a frost? A trifle too bizarre, sir, in my opinion. But lots of fellows have asked me who my tailor is. Doubtless in order to avoid him, sir. He's supposed to be one of the best men in London. I'm saying nothing against his moral character, sir. I hesitated a bit. I had a
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。哦，吉夫斯，我说。关于那套捷克西装。是的，先生？真的很俗气吗？在我看来，先生，稍微有点怪异。但很多人问我裁缝是谁。毫无疑问是为了避开他，先生。他可是伦敦最好的裁缝之一。我并没有诋毁他的人品，先生。我犹豫了一下。我有一种
feeling that I was passing into this chappie's clutches, and that if I gave in now I should become just like poor old Aubrey Fothergill, unable to call my soul my own. On the other hand, this was obviously a cove of rare intelligence, and it would be a comfort in lots of ways to have him doing the thinking for me. I made up my mind. All right, Jeeves, I said. You know, give the bally thing away to somebody. He looked at me like a father gazing tenderly at the wayward child.
感觉，我正在落入这个家伙的掌控之中，如果我现在屈服，我就变得和可怜的老奥布里·福瑟吉尔一样，连自己的灵魂都无法做主。另一方面，这显然是个极其聪明的人，让他替我思考在很多方面都是一种安慰。我下定了决心。好吧，吉夫斯，我说。你知道的，把那该死的东西送给谁吧。他看着我，就像一位父亲慈爱地注视着任性的孩子。
Thank you, sir. I gave it to the undergardener last night. A little more tea, sir? So that's Bertie Worcester and his gentleman's gentleman Jeeves in Jeeves Takes Charge, which was originally published in 1916. It's the story in which Bertie and Jeeves first meet. P.G. Woodhouse's classic couple. The dynamic at the heart of his stories that delighted so many people for so long. Tom, are you a Jeeves or a Bertie? I think I am probably more of a Jeeves. Really?
谢谢您，先生。我昨晚把它送给园丁助手了。再来点茶吗，先生？这就是伯蒂·伍斯特和他的贴身男仆吉夫斯在《吉夫斯当家》中的故事，该书最初出版于 1916 年。这是伯蒂和吉夫斯第一次见面的故事。P.G. 伍德豪斯笔下的经典搭档。他故事核心的这种动态关系，长期以来让许多人感到愉悦。汤姆，你是吉夫斯型还是伯蒂型？我想我可能更像吉夫斯。真的吗？
And what are you possibly basing that claim? I prefer understated sophistication, Dominic. Right. Rather than flash excess. Is that why you're doing this podcast in braces? I'm looking at them right now. So I'm wearing a suit and it's a suit with braces and every gentleman knows that the hang of trousers is better with braces than with a belt. Yeah. Although I notice a soft collared shirt with a suit. Well, that's just the little hint of rebellion. Right. The little hint of kind of artistic license. I think Jeeves would let me get away with it.
你凭什么这么说？我更喜欢低调的精致，多米尼克。对。而不是浮夸的奢华。这就是你戴着背带录制播客的原因吗？我正看着它们呢。我穿着西装，而且是配背带的西装，每一位绅士都知道，裤子用背带挂着比用皮带挂着效果更好。是的。虽然我注意到你穿西装配了一件软领衬衫。嗯，那只是一点点反叛的暗示。对。一种艺术许可的暗示。我想吉夫斯会让我这么做的。
Trifle too bizarre, sir, in my opinion. Are you Bertie or Jeeves? I'm probably much more Jeeves-like. I hate anybody who dresses in an even remotely unconventional way. In a flash way, a flamboyant way. Yeah, exactly. I dislike such people instantly. So definitely much more of a Jeeves. So this discussion is germane from a historical point of view, isn't it? Because today's subject is the subject of the suit. And it kind of struck me that that passage sums up what has basically always been a dynamic in the history of the suit. Because the suit is a kind of uniform. Of course. Yeah.
在我看来，稍微有点怪异，先生。你是伯蒂型还是吉夫斯型？我可能更像吉夫斯。我讨厌任何穿着打扮哪怕有一点点非传统的人。那种浮夸的、招摇的方式。是的，没错。我立刻就会讨厌这样的人。所以绝对更像吉夫斯。那么从历史的角度来看，这个讨论很有意义，不是吗？因为今天的主题是西装。我突然想到，那段话总结了西装历史上一直存在的一种动态。因为西装是一种制服。当然。是的。
It's the official wear of men in Britain, in the West more generally, and increasingly across the world. It's literally derived from uniforms, as we'll discuss, isn't it? We will be coming to this because we're going to be looking at how it evolves and where it ultimately comes from. But you have there the sense that it's a uniform for the elites. So Jeeves' sense is that there is a correct way to wear a suit. It should clearly be of a certain cut, a certain style, and that you express your elite status through understanding the rules that govern the tailoring of a fine suit. And against that, there is the sense that the suit is something drab, that it kind of bleeds you of character, that it renders you something anonymous, a kind of a drone, not in the sense
它是英国男性的正式着装，在西方更普遍，并且在世界范围内也日益普及。正如我们将要讨论的那样，它实际上源于制服，不是吗？我们将谈到这一点，因为我们将研究它是如何演变的，以及它最终来自哪里。但你从中感觉到它是精英的制服。所以吉夫斯的观点是，穿西装有一种正确的方式。它显然应该有特定的剪裁、特定的风格，而你通过理解支配高级西装剪裁的规则来表达你的精英地位。与之相对的是一种感觉，即西装是乏味的东西，它会剥夺你的个性，让你变得默默无闻，像个无人机，不是指
of the drones club that Bertie Worcester belongs to, but a kind of a worker bee. Where they wear very extravagant suits. Yeah. Yes. But that people might try and rebel against that. Yeah. You know, show themselves to be a character by wearing a loud check suit or something like that. Yes. And I think that in both of them, there is an expression of an anxiety or perhaps a consciousness that men's formal clothing compared to women's formal clothing is incredibly boring. Would you say that's a reasonable take? I think in men's clothing,
伯蒂·伍斯特所属的无人机俱乐部，而是一种工蜂。他们穿着非常夸张的西装。是的。但人们可能会试图反抗这一点。是的。你知道，通过穿一件花哨的格子西装或类似的东西来展示自己的个性。是的。我认为在这两者中，都表达了一种焦虑，或者说一种意识，即与女性正式服装相比，男性正式服装极其无聊。你认为这是一个合理的看法吗？我认为在男装方面，
there's maybe been a great anxiety about transgression. Not that that's not there in women's clothing, but I think men are more tightly circumscribed. You know, the palette of colours has become much more restrained, hasn't it, for men than for women over time in the last 300 years or so. You know, you look at a photo from the 1950s or something, and people are wearing often a very limited range of colours. I mean, basically all grey, dark blue, black and so on. But even today, if you think of weddings, men always look boring compared to the women. Or say the Oscars, the red carpet.
可能一直存在着对越界的巨大焦虑。并不是说女装中没有这种焦虑，但我认为男性的着装受到更严格的限制。你知道，在过去 300 年左右的时间里，男性的色彩调色板比女性变得更加克制了，不是吗？你看一张 1950 年代的照片之类的，人们通常穿着非常有限的颜色。我的意思是，基本上全是灰色、深蓝色、黑色等等。但即使在今天，如果你想到婚礼，男士看起来总是比女士无聊。或者说奥斯卡颁奖典礼，红地毯。
Yes, that's a good example. They have amazing opportunities to dress up any way they like. And men, oh, he's got a slightly darker tuxedo or whatever. Yeah. And so I thought it would be interesting to have a look at why that is, why men's clothing is so circumscribed compared to women's clothing. Yeah, but Tom, promise me you're not going to use the word tuxedo again. Yeah, but you do on the red carpet when you're in Hollywood, don't you? I wouldn't. When I'm in Hollywood, I don't use it.
是的，这是一个很好的例子。她们有绝佳的机会以任何她们喜欢的方式打扮。而男士，哦，他穿了一件稍微深一点的燕尾服之类的。是的。所以我认为看看为什么会这样，为什么男装与女装相比受到如此多的限制会很有趣。是的，但汤姆，答应我你不会再用“燕尾服”（tuxedo）这个词了。是的，但你在好莱坞走红毯时会用这个词，不是吗？我不会。当我在好莱坞时，我不用它。
Well, we will very much be focusing on the origins of the suit which is in england i'm proud to say but it is kind of globally ubiquitous isn't it it is but it is also i think very very culturally contingent yeah and if you think the broad sweep of clothing right the way back to ancient egypt or sumeria or china or whatever or rome with the toga. It's unusual for the way that it kind of molds itself to the body because generally clothing has kind of hung in kind of like robes. So the suit is much more fitted. And again, this is pretty recent development seen in the broad sweep of history. And it's a very, in origins, it's a very European style of
好吧，我们将非常关注西装的起源，我很自豪地说它起源于英国，但它在全球范围内确实无处不在，不是吗？是的，但我认为它在文化上也具有很强的偶然性。是的，如果你回顾服装的广泛演变，一直追溯到古埃及、苏美尔、中国或罗马的托加长袍。它以那种贴合身体的方式出现是很不寻常的，因为通常服装都是像长袍一样垂挂着的。所以西装更合身。同样，从历史的长河来看，这是一个非常近期的发展。而且从起源上讲，这是一种非常欧洲风格的
dress. And I'm afraid, Dominic, that although the suit as we understand it, I think, develops in England, of course, the word is French. Yes. It has an element of following something or succeeding something, which I guess the point of a suit is that the different components depend upon one another. They're not just random bits of clothing. Exactly. Yes, they're coordinated and generally they're from the same material. Yeah. Yes, they're coordinated and generally they're from the same material. And the word emerges in the 14th century, which is a time when something really interesting is happening in the history of fashion. That for the first time really in history, in Latin Christendom,
着装。多米尼克，恐怕虽然我们所理解的西装是在英国发展起来的，但这个词本身是法语。是的。它有一种跟随某物或继承某物的含义，我想西装的意义就在于它的不同组件相互依赖。它们不仅仅是随机的服装碎片。完全正确。是的，它们是协调一致的，通常由相同的材料制成。是的，它们是协调一致的，通常由相同的材料制成。这个词出现在 14 世纪，当时时尚史上发生了一些非常有趣的事情。在拉丁基督教世界，时尚的理解第一次真正以越来越快的速度演变。据我们所知，这在以前从未发生过。我认为其原因与纺织业的发展、羊毛工业的发展有关，即我们谈到的英国与佛兰德斯之间在百年战争背景下的那种联系。这似乎推动了一种观念，即服装风格是可以十年一变的东西。我想黑死病可能也有……哦，你想炫耀，因为你明天可能就死了。是可以十年一变的东西。我想黑死病可能也有……哦，你想炫耀，因为你明天可能就死了。
the understanding of fashion is evolving at an increasingly rapid rate. And this isn't something that's really happened before, as far as we can tell. And the reasons for that, I think, are tied up with the development of weaving, of the wool industry, that that nexus between England and Flanders that we talked about in connection with the Hundred Years' War. And that seems to be propelling the sense that styles of clothing are something that can change decade to decade. And I imagine also the Black Death might have had... Oh, you want to show off because you might be dead tomorrow. something that can change decade to decade. And I imagine also the Black Death might have had… Oh, you want to show off because you might be dead tomorrow.
是的。如果你想想我们在节目中已经提到的 14 世纪时尚的例子，我们有乔叟和他那非凡的……短束腰外衣。是的。是的。他那露出臀部的束腰外衣。还有你在纽卡斯尔夜店排队时会穿的那种束腰外衣。完全正确。
Yeah. If you think about examples of 14th century fashion that we've already mentioned on the show, we had Chaucer with his extraordinary… Short tunic. Yes. Yeah. His buttock displaying tunic. And a tunic you'd wear queuing up for a Newcastle nightclub. Exactly.
我们还提到了理查二世和法国国王查理六世之间的那次峰会。是的。有趣的是，理查二世是个爱炫耀的人，是个衣架子。他不断地更换长袍。他所做的一切都是为了展示，不是吗？这一定取决于对布料的获取。所以很明显，你提到了羊毛。是的。但一定还有更廉价的染色技术，
And also we had that summit between Richard II and Charles VI, the King of France. Yeah. What was interesting about that was that it was Richard II who was the show pony, the clothes horse. He was kind of endlessly changing his robes. And he's all about display, isn't he? And that must depend upon access to fabric. So obviously, you know, you mentioned wool. Yeah. But also there must be dyeing more cheaply,
一定有技术变革，一定有熟练的裁缝。你必须拥有某种经济和技术基础，时尚才能成为所谓的上层建筑。绝对是这样。所以，在 14、15 世纪一直到 16 世纪，人们非常强调从不同的供应商那里采购构成你整套服装的各个元素。比如纽扣供应商或拉夫领供应商等等。《威尼斯商人》里说任何人都可以添加装饰，这就是为什么裁缝总是向顾客学习，并执行他们要求的任何任务，仅此而已。所以裁缝的角色几乎是卑微的，是的，他只是为了提供便利，这很有趣，因为我们现在绝不会那样争论，对吧？因为现在人们对裁缝很尊重，任何曾经有过哪怕是
there must be technological change, there must be skilled tailors. You must have the kind of economic and technological basis from which fashion becomes the superstructure, as it were. Absolutely. So as yet, in the 14th, 15th through into the 16th century, there's very much an emphasis on sourcing the various elements of what becomes your suite of clothing from different suppliers. So button suppliers or rough suppliers or whatever. There isn't and merchants of venice and it says anyone can add decoration and this is why tailors always learn from their customers and carry out whatever task they ask for and nothing more so the sense of a tailor as a kind of almost menial role yeah he's simply there to facilitate which is interesting because we would never make that argument now right because now there is a deference to the tailor anyone who's ever had something even
修改过衣服的人，无论是裁缝还是女裁缝，你知道，他们才是专家，因为现在人们对裁缝很尊重。任何曾经有过哪怕是修改过衣服的人，无论是裁缝还是女裁缝，他们都是专家。专家是王，而不是顾客，对吧？但在那个年代，顾客才是王。绝对是这样。我认为在某种程度上，这是因为在整个欧洲，服装是阶级的象征。所以几乎到处都有禁奢法，即规定什么阶层的人可以穿什么的法律。人们认为，能够支配非常奢华的材料、精致的珠宝，是贵族地位的标志。但有趣的是，在信奉新教的国家，比如你想到伦勃朗画中的荷兰市民，他们很朴素。英国的清教徒也是如此。
changed you know by a tailor or a seamstress or whatever you know they're the experts because now there is a deference to the tailor. Anyone who's ever had something even changed by a tailor or a seamstress or whatever, they're the expert. The expert is king, not the customer, right? But in those days, the customer was king. Absolutely. And I think in part, that is because across Europe, clothing serves as a signifier of class. So pretty much everywhere, there are sumptuary laws, so laws specifying what class of person can wear what. And the sense is that the ability to command very, very lavish materials, exquisite jewels, is a marker of aristocratic status. But what's interesting in Protestant countries, so you think of Rembrandt's paintings of the Dutch burghers, they're sober. And the same thing is happening in England with the Puritans.
甚至在伊丽莎白时代，就已经开始有清教徒谴责宫廷服饰的奢华是不虔诚、不爱国且不男人的。这在斯图亚特王朝时期，特别是在内战前夕以及内战本身的过程中，成为了你在意识形态光谱上所处位置的一个巨大的标志。所以，你知道，我小时候读《淑女贝德》书籍和历史教科书之类的，你会看到白金汉公爵，他有着巨大的腿，穿着非常非常花哨的长筒袜和紧身短上衣之类的。还有一个遮羞布。是的，装饰非常华丽。是的。
And even in the Elizabethan period, you were starting to get Puritans who are condemning the extravagance of court dress as ungodly, unpatriotic, and unmanly. And this is something that through the, say, into the Stuart period, Stuart period and particularly in the build up to the Civil War and then Civil War itself, it becomes a massive, massive signifier of where you stand on the ideological spectrum. So, you know, growing up as a child reading ladybed books and history textbooks and things, you know, you would have the Duke of Buckingham on the one hand with his enormous legs, very, very fancy sort of stockings and a doublet or whatever he's wearing. And a codpiece. Yeah, very richly ornamented. Yeah.
然后另一方面，那些你在社交媒体上经常看到的清教徒在 1630 年代不赞成枫树的著名照片。他们穿着极其单调的黑色西装。但有趣的是，这些西装仍然很贵，对吧？非常贵。是的，因为黑色很容易褪色。所以能够维持一套黑色西装本身就是地位的标志。但这显然是在发表一种意识形态声明。如果你拒绝宫廷的珠宝、拉夫领和丝绸，你就是在表明你在内战日益紧张的局势中所处的位置。所以奥斯卡·王尔德有一句精彩的评论，他当然对时尚非常感兴趣，
And then the other hand, those famous pictures that you'll often see on social media of Puritans disapproving of maples in the 1630s. And they're wearing incredibly drab black suits. But interestingly, those suits would still have been quite expensive, right? Very. Yeah, because black is very prone to fading. So to be able to maintain a black suit of clothing is itself a marker of status. But it's obviously making an ideological statement. If you reject the jewels and the ruffs and the silks of the court, you are saying where you are relative to the growing tensions in the Civil War. So there's a brilliant comment by Oscar Wilde, who of course is very interested in fashion,
骑士党和清教徒因其服装而有趣，而不是因其信念而有趣。我的意思是，这是一个笑话，因为信念当然是通过服装表达出来的。是的，绝对是这样。所以我认为这就是西装发明的背景，在开始研究这个之前我并没有意识到这一点。我们几乎可以将西装的发明日期定在一个精确的时刻。它发生在内战之后，共和国之后，查理二世复辟之后。是在 1666 年 10 月 7 日，当然也就是伦敦大火一个月后，是的，所以这就是它的背景，塞缪尔·佩皮斯在他的日记中记录道：国王昨天在议会上宣布了他的决心，
that Cavaliers and Puritans are interesting for their costumes and not for their convictions. I mean, it's a joke because of course the convictions are expressed through the costumes. Yeah, absolutely. So this, I think, is the context for the invention of the suit, which I had not realised until I started researching this. We can pretty much date the invention of the suit to a precise moment. And it comes after the Civil War, after the Republic, after the restoration of Charles II. And it's on the 7th of October, 1666, which of course is a month after the Great fire yeah so that is the context for it and samuel peeps in his diary records it the king have yesterday in council declared his resolution
要确立一种他永远不会改变的服装时尚，那将是一件背心，我不太清楚具体是什么，但它是为了教导贵族节俭，并且会产生好的影响。所以背心，背心就是后来英式英语中的马甲，对吧？但它很长，一直垂到膝盖或膝盖以下。它顺着外套的线条，穿在里面。结果基本上就是西装的三件套。你有外套，也就是后来的夹克。你有马裤，显然是配长筒袜穿的。还有背心，随着时间的推移变成了马甲。我认为它被设计得朴素，正如佩皮斯所说，是为了在大火之后教导贵族节俭，当时人们在道德上对
of setting a fashion for clothes which he will never alter it will be a vest i know not well how but it is to teach the nobility thrift and will do good so a vest so a vest is what will become a waistcoat right in british english but it's the long kind of reaches down to the knees or below the knees. And it kind of follows the line of the coat and is worn underneath it. And so the result is basically the three pieces of a suit. You have the coat, what will become the jacket. You have the britches, which are obviously worn with stockings. And you have the vest, which over time will become a waistcoat. I think the sense that it is designed to be sober, and as Peep says, to teach the nobility thrift in the wake of the great fire, where there is anxiety morally about
大火对上帝的旨意意味着什么感到焦虑，同时也对首都化为灰烬后的经济未来感到焦虑。这是一个方面。但它也特别旨在促进羊毛贸易，这仍然是英国经济的绝对引擎，同时也为了培养一种独特的英国时尚感。当然，查理二世即使在与路易十四勾结时，路易十四在法国凡尔赛宫，他也想维护自己宫廷的尊严。但这里有一件有趣的事情，因为英国和法国宫廷之间存在真正的互动，因为也是查理二世将领带带到了英国。所以当时非常流行所谓的领巾。它们被称为领巾，因为它们据说是受到克罗地亚雇佣兵的启发，那些来自军事边境、参加三十年战争的雇佣兵。Hrvatska，领巾。
what the fire might mean about God's purposes, but also anxiety about the future of the economy with the capital in ashes. That's an aspect. But it's also specifically to boost the wool trade, which remains an absolute motor of the English economy, and also to foster a distinctively English sense of fashion. And of course, Charles II, even while he's kind of in cahoots with Louis XIV, who's over in France and Versailles-ing away, he wants to uphold the dignity of his own court. But there's an interesting thing here, because there's a real interplay between the English and French courts because it's also Charles II who brings the tie to England. So there'd been a great fashion for cravats, as they were called. And they were called cravats because they were supposedly inspired by Croatian mercenaries, mercenaries from the military frontier, fighting the Thirty Years' War. Hrvatska, cravat.
太迷人了。是的。1680 年有一个叫兰德尔·霍姆的人，他是纹章学专家，他说，领巾是颈部的另一种装饰，只不过是一条长毛巾围在领子上，然后用蝴蝶结系在前面。这就是所有此类穿戴的起源。但你看，即使在这一点上，它们也在改变。因为他说，但现在通过裁缝的艺术和发明，制作它们的新方法太多了，要描述它们简直是一项艰巨的任务。
Fascinating. Yeah. And there's a guy in 1680 called Randall Holm, who was a heraldry expert, who said, a cravat is another kind of adornment for the neck being nothing else but a long towel put about the collar and so tied before with a bow knot. This is the original of all such wearings. But see, even at this point, they're changing. Because he says, but now by the art and inventions of the seamsters, there are so many new ways of making them that it would be a task to name much more to describe them.
太刺激了。所以人们已经在穿领带的祖先了。他们从法国那里得到了这个，最终，他们认为是来自克罗地亚，所以才有了这个名字。嗯，所以我认为问题在于，英国宫廷在很大程度上处于法国宫廷的阴影之下，这就是为什么查理想要发展自己的风格。所以很明显，他不能阻止人们采用领巾和法国时尚等等。但他试图建立一种独特的英国风格，路易十四对此的回应是让他所有的仆人都穿上它。哦不，那是有含义的。
Thrilling. So already people are wearing the ancestor of a tie. They've got that from France and ultimately, so they think, from Croatia, hence the name. Well, so this is the issue, I think, that the English court is very much in the shadow of the French court, which is why Charles wants to develop his own style. So obviously he can't stop people adopting cravats and French fashions and so on. But his attempt to establish a distinctively English style, Louis XIV's response to this is to dress all his footmen in it. Oh no, that had a meaning.
是的。但查理二世坚持自己的立场。听众可能想知道，我的意思是，查理二世是“快乐君主”。他以和卖橘子的女孩调情和到处游荡而闻名。为什么如此强调相对的朴素？所以大卫·库奇塔，他写了那本名字很棒的书《三件套西装与现代男性气质》，他将其总结为一种对共和党反时尚立场的保皇党式挪用。所以查理本质上是在试图中和共和党对宫廷形象的反对。他意识到宫廷的形象是负面的。他不想完全变成清教徒，但他想在挪用共和党反对宫廷的某些方面的同时，试图向路易十四竖起中指。
Yeah. But Charles II sticks to his guns. And listeners may be wondering, I mean, Charles II is the merry monarch. He's famous for getting off with the orange sellers and ladding around. Why this emphasis on relative sobriety? So David Kuchta, who has written the brilliantly named book, The Three-Piece Suit and Modern Masculinity, he sums it up as a royalist appropriation of a Republican opposition to fashion. So essentially what Charles is doing is trying to neutralise Republican opposition to the image of the court. He's aware that the court's image is negative. He doesn't want to go the full Puritan, but he wants to try and flick a V sign at Louis XIV while simultaneously appropriating aspects of Republican opposition to the court.
所以这是一个查理二世政治平衡术的精彩可见例子。是的，这是中间道路。伦敦的商业阶层，因为在内战之后，没有颁布禁奢法的希望，宫廷也没有希望能够合法限制宫廷外的人穿什么，所以复辟时期的商人们穿得和朝臣一模一样，对吧？所以查理本质上是试图通过让他们看起来像是属于昨天的时尚来削弱他们。所以我认为这就是正在发生的事情。结果是，它确立了一种反时尚即时尚的观念。这是复辟时期英国政治的产物。我的意思是，这真的很迷人。实际上，这意味着男性奢华的公开展示，正如清教徒在伊丽莎白时代所说的那样，被视为女性化和不爱国过度的标志。
So it's a brilliant visible example of Charles II's Political Balancing Act. Yeah, it's the via media. commercial classes in London because in the wake of the civil war there's no prospect of sumptuary laws there's no prospect of the court being able to legalize restrictions against what people outside the court can wear so merchants in in the restoration are dressing up exactly like courtiers right and so Charles is essentially trying to undercut them by leaving them looking as though they kind of belong to yesterday's fashion. So I think that that is what is going on. And the consequence is that it kind of establishes a sense of anti-fashion as being fashionable. And it's something that's bred of the politics of Restoration England. I mean, it's really fascinating. And effectively, it means that overt displays of masculine luxury, rather as the Puritans have been saying back in the Elizabethan period, are seen as markers of effeminacy and unpatriotic excess.
所以一些听众会记得我们做的关于“英国烤牛肉”以及对外国炖菜和杂烩的不信任的播客。这没什么不同，对吧？朴素和清醒。是的，我认为这真的很相似。特别是那些受到 18 世纪英国皇家海军启发的风格。哦，完全是。是的。它们被视为，你知道，这是新教的男子气概。一个新教徒，一个爱国者，不会穿那种荒谬夸张的法式领巾。不。所以这基本上是隐蔽的
So some listeners will remember the podcast we did about the roast beef of old England and the distrust of foreign fricassees and ragus. This is not dissimilar, right? The plainness and sobriety. Yeah, I think it's really similar. And especially styles that are inspired by, let's say, the Royal Navy in the 18th century. Oh, completely. Yeah. They are seen as, you know, this is Protestant manliness. A Protestant man, a patriot, does not wear a ludicrously extravagant Frenchified cravat. No. So it's basically inconspicuous
消费。你的消费展示越隐蔽，就越好。正如你所建议的那样，在 18 世纪，这种源于宫廷的时尚传播到了全国各地。它绝对是由这种风格在军服中的回响所驱动的。军官、红衫军、海军军官，他们来自全国各地。所以当他们退休或回家时，他们带走了这种风格。然后它就变成了全国各地，远离伦敦，远离宫廷的人们能够采用的东西。我认为另一个巨大的影响，自 16 世纪以来一直如此，是激进的新教徒。所以到了 18 世纪，就是卫理公会教徒，就是
consumption. The more inconspicuous your displays of consumption are, the better it is. And as you suggested, in the 18th century, this fashion which emerges from the court spreads across the whole of the country. And it is absolutely driven by the fact that there is an echo of this style in military uniform. Officers, redcoats, naval officers, they're being drawn from across the country. And so when they retire or go back home, they are taking this style. And then it becomes something that people across the country, far from London, far from the court, are then able to adopt. And I think the other massive influence on it, which it has been since the 16th century, kind of radical Protestants. So in the 18th century, it would be Methodists, it would
贵格会教徒。所以约翰·卫斯理，卫理公会的伟大创始人，在 1760 年，他出版了这本听起来很了不起的小册子《给卫理公会教徒关于着装的建议》。即使到现在，我也把它当作我的时尚圣经。我知道。这很桑德布鲁克。不要买天鹅绒、丝绸、高级亚麻布、多余的东西，不要买纯粹的装饰品，即使它们再流行。不要穿任何东西，即使你已经有了，颜色刺眼，或者任何花哨、闪亮、炫耀的东西。不要穿任何处于时尚巅峰的东西。不要穿任何吸引旁观者目光的东西。我也不建议男士穿彩色马甲、闪亮的长筒袜、
be Quakers. So John Wesley, the great founder of Methodism, in 1760, he published this tremendous sounding pamphlet, Advice to the People Called Methodists with Regard to Dress. I use that as my fashion Bible even now. I know. It's very Sandbrook. Buy no velvets, no silks, no fine linen, no superfluities, no mere ornaments, though ever so much in fashion. Wear nothing though you have it already, which is of a glaring colour or which is any kind, gay, glistening, showy. Nothing made in the very height of fashion. Nothing to attract the eyes of the bystanders. Neither do I advise men to wear coloured waistcoats, shining stockings,
闪闪发光或昂贵的扣子或纽扣，无论是在外套上还是袖子上。我的意思是，那是吉夫斯真实的声音，不是吗？不要吸引旁观者的目光。是的。稍微有点怪异，先生。在整个 P.G. 伍德豪斯的故事中，每当伯蒂试图做任何稍微非传统的事情时，你知道，一种有趣的新颜色，一种新图案，吉夫斯只是说，不，吉夫斯是一个低教会派、着装倾向的人，不是吗？是的，绝对是这样。而且它变得政治化了，因为当然，对此有一种反应。对此有一种持续的反应。所以背心，这种穿在外套下面的长袍，正如我们早期关于
glittering or costly buckles or buttons, either on their coats or on their sleeves. I mean, that is the authentic voice of Jeeves, isn't it? Nothing to attract the eyes of bystanders. Yeah. A trifle too bizarre, sir. And throughout the PG Woodhouse stories, whenever Bertie tries to do anything slightly unconventional, you know, an interesting new colour, a new pattern, Jeeves just says, no, Jeeves is a man of low church, sartorial inclinations, isn't he? Yes, absolutely. And it becomes political because, of course, there is a reaction against this. There is a constant reaction against this. So the vest, this long kind of robe that's underneath the coat, As listeners to a very early episode we did on how
波斯如何影响一切的剧集听众所知，阿里·安萨里说这最终是波斯的。它通过奥斯曼宫廷，然后通过英国人对莫卧儿宫廷和莫卧儿时尚日益增加的接触来到英国。所以有一种感觉，虽然查理二世指定它应该是黑色的，但如果你对奥斯曼人或莫卧儿人有某种熟悉，就有机会去尝试那种完全东方、华丽的图案之类的。所以这是一个方面。纳瓦布人会喜欢那样。那些在印度变得富有的人。当然，这是在发表政治声明。不过，那些把打扮作为一种向体面社会竖中指的方式的人的经典例子
Persia has influenced everything with Ali Ansari, and Ali said how this is ultimately Persian. And it comes to England via the Ottoman court and then through the increasing exposure of the British to the Mughal court and Mughal fashions. So there is a sense of kind of, although Charles II had specified that it should be black, there are opportunities So there is a sense of kind of, although Charles II has specified that it should be black, there are opportunities if you have a kind of familiarity with the Ottomans or the moguls to go the full oriental, flamboyant patterns and things. So that is an aspect. Nabobs would go for that. People who've become rich in India. And that of course is making a political statement. The classic example though, of people who are dressing up as a way of kind of flicking a V sign at respectable society
是海盗的形象。你想到长约翰·西尔弗或杰克·斯派洛。我的意思是，海盗那样打扮的全部意义在于，对他们是多么蔑视社会规范进行一种着装上的表达。或者那是插画家投射到海盗身上的东西？换句话说，如果你真的是个海盗，也许你没有那么多非常花哨的领巾。但如果你在画海盗，你想把他们描绘成处于传统朴素界限之外的亡命之徒，你会那样画他们。不，我认为那种角色，我们称之为花花公子。
is the figure of the pirate. You think of Long John Silver or Jack Sparrow. I mean, the whole point of why pirates are dressing up like that is to make a kind of sartorial expression of how contemptuous they are of the norms of society. Or is that something that is projected onto pirates by illustrators? In other words, if you really are a pirate, maybe you don't have access to that many very fancy cravats. But if you're drawing pirates, you want to portray them as outlaws outside the bounds of conventional kind of sobriety, you would draw them in that way. No, I think the kind of the character, let's call it the fop.
对。因为强盗也是这样。哦，是的，当然。是的。着装上的奢华是犯罪的标志。所以在 18 世纪的过程中，这意味着着装上的奢华展示变得越来越具有政治攻击性。这方面的经典例子是我们很久以前做过的，通心粉（Macaronis）。
Right. Because you get it with highwaymen as well. Oh, yes, of course. Yeah. The sense that extravagance in dress is a mark of criminality. And so over the course of the 18th century, it means that extravagant displays of dress become more and more politically offensive. And the classic example of this is one that we did ages ago, the macaronis.
英意关系，通心粉。是的。所以这是在 1770 年代，这是一种非常非常高的、扑粉假发的风格。如果不架梯子，你没法把帽子戴在假发上。帽子很小，前面像泰晤士河平底船的船头一样尖。马甲完全没有品味，牛津杂志，我想我们在那期节目中引用过这个，我们引用过，我记得这个精彩的引语，有一种动物既不是雄性也不是雌性，所以再次强调，穿奢华的衣服是女性化的，一种中性性别，最近在我们中间兴起，
Anglo-Italian relations, the macaroni. Yeah. So this is in the 1770s and it's a style for very, very kind of tall, powdered wigs. You can't put your hat on top of the wig without somebody going up on a ladder to put it there. A hat's very small and sharpened before like the bow of a Thames wherry. Waistcoats out of all taste and the oxford magazine and i think we quoted this in the episode that we did we did i remember this great brilliant quote that there is a kind of animal neither male nor female so again that sense that to wear extravagant jess is effeminate a thing of the neuter gender lately started up
它被称为通心粉。它说话没有意义。它微笑没有愉悦。它吃东西没有胃口。它骑马没有锻炼。它寻花问柳没有激情。而且“通心粉”是一个意大利词，所以它与欧洲大陆有关。是的，欧洲大陆天主教世界的奢华。完全正确。所以这也引起了对法国的怀疑，因为法国宫廷传统上一直是时尚的仲裁者。同样，这和你说的关于烤牛肉的话一样，穿朴素的西装就是给自己贴上爱国英国人的标签，鄙视天主教的专制和虚饰。而且，我认为，在拜伦的剧集中，我们谈到了对鸡奸的几乎是病毒式的恐慌。同样，我认为这也被联系在一起了，如果你
among us it is called a macaroni it It talks without meaning. It smiles without pleasantry. It eats without appetite. It rides without exercise. It wenches without passion. And macaroni is an Italian word, so it's associated with the continent. Yeah, the luxury of continental Catholic Europe. Exactly. And so that also breeds a suspicion for France because the French court had always traditionally been the arbiter of fashion. And again, it's what you're saying about roast beef, that to wear a sober suit is to brand yourself as a patriotic Briton, despising Catholic absolutism and flummery. And also, I think, in the Byron episodes, we talked about the virulent panic almost about sodomy. And again, I think that this is getting tied up, that if you are
穿着一件华丽的马甲，那么你就会受到各种怀疑。当然，这反映了一个事实，即女性不受这些限制。所以女性可以继续以一种我认为查理一世宫廷的人会认出的风格着装。而男性则不然。我认为还有一种感觉，它正在施加一种日益增长的意识，即男性着装是为了做事。所以他们穿衣服是为了战斗，为了站在船上，为了行军去打仗。而女性则被束缚在紧身胸衣和巨大的蓬松裙子里。实际上，这是一种非常非常难以做任何事情的服装，而不是
wearing a flamboyant vest, then you're going to come under all kinds of suspicions. And of course, that reflects the fact that women are not subject to these strictures. So women can continue to dress in a style that would have been recognisable, I think, to people at Charles I's court. Whereas men, that's not the case. And I think there is also a sense in which it is imposing an increasing sense that men are dressed to do things. So they're dressed to fight, they're dressed to stand on ships, they're dressed to march off to war. Whereas women are being laced into corsets and stays and vast voluminous skirts. And it actually, it's clothing that is very, very difficult to do anything in rather than kind
坐着看起来很美。嗯，重点是，这不就是重点吗？卫斯理说的那句话，不要吸引旁观者的目光，因为你要做事。对于女性，假设是你不会动，你会吸引旁观者的目光。你的工作就是被看。这就是区别。所以如果作为一个男人，你通过奢华的着装和不切实际的服装形式吸引了旁观者的目光，那么你就和一个女人一样。特别是在拿破仑战争期间，当时对男子气概有如此高的要求，那么这对处于战争状态的社会的道德标准来说就变得非常非常具有威胁性。
of sit and look beautiful. Well, the point is, isn't this the point? That thing that Wesley said, nothing to attract the eyes of the bystanders, because you'll be doing things. For a woman, the assumption is you will not move and you will attract the eyes of the bystanders. Your job is to be looked at. And that is the difference. And so if as a man, you are attracting the gaze of the bystander through your extravagant dress and through kind of impractical forms of clothing, then you are like a woman. And particularly in the Napoleonic Wars, where there's such a premium on masculinity, then that becomes very, very threatening to the moral standards of a society at war.
对。因为全面战争，人们以前所未有的方式动员起来对抗拿破仑。海军中非常流行海军时尚等等。但有趣的是，正是在这段时期，我们有了花花公子（Dandy）的兴起，不是吗？所以是在反抗那种东西。我不这么认为。因为我认为一个满身都是扭捏的拐杖、美人痣、扑粉假花花公子（Fop）和一个花花公子（Dandy）之间有本质的区别。因为花花公子是在提炼，而不是颠覆这种英国式的隐蔽消费时尚。这就是定制萨维尔街西装的理念，吉夫斯会非常喜欢，这就是它被
Right. Because a total war, people are mobilizing in ways unprecedented against Napoleon. There's a huge popularity of kind of naval fashions and so on in the Navy generally. But interestingly, it's during this period that we have the rise of the dandy, don't we? So kicking against that. I don't think it does. Because I think there's a quantum difference between a fop who's all kind of mincing canes, beauty spots, powdered wigs, and a dandy. Because the dandies are refining, not subverting, this kind of British fashion for inconspicuous consumption. And this is where the idea of the bespoke Savile Row suit, which Jeeves would be all over, this is where it gets
提炼的地方。当然，与它经典联系在一起的人是乔治·布鲁梅尔，博·布鲁梅尔，他是摄政时期花花公子的原型，他来自中产阶级背景，根本不是贵族。他成为了时尚的仲裁者，以至于人们会来看他穿衣，这成了当时最伟大的活动之一，嗯，我可以引用一位节目的朋友吗，多米尼克，取决于是谁，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，哦，看在上帝的份上，你真的，好吧，但我认为这可能是弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫说的唯一一件你可能会赞同的事情。好吧。所以谈到博·布鲁梅尔，他的衣服似乎以其剪裁的完美和色彩的安静和谐融为一体。没有一个强调点，一切都很独特。所以实际上，博·布鲁梅尔是
refined. And of course, the guy who is classically associated with it is George Brummel, Beau Brummel, who is the archetype of the dandy in the regency period he's from middle class background yeah not aristocratic at all he becomes such an arbiter of fashion that people will come and watch him dress it's kind of one of the great activities to do and um shall I quote a friend of the show Dominic uh depends who it is Virginia Woolf oh for god's sake you really okay but I think this may be the only thing that Virginia Wolfe said that you might approve of. Okay. So talking about Beau Brummel, his clothes seem to melt into each other with the perfection of their cut and the quiet harmony of their colour. Without a single point of emphasis, everything was distinguished. So actually, Beau Brummel is
时尚的仲裁者，因为他综合了低调，并使之成为一种美。所以基本上是布鲁梅尔让马裤变得不流行，并引入了长裤。他是长裤之王，是的。因为长裤是一种更简单的服装形式。而且他也喜欢领巾。你知道他怎么评价自己吗？他说，我，布鲁梅尔，让现代男人穿上了长裤、深色外套、白衬衫和干净的亚麻布。我敢说这足以确保我的名声。他没说错，不是吗？实际上那个描述，很遗憾他用
the arbiter of fashion because he is synthesising understatement and making it a thing of beauty. So it's Brummel basically who makes britches unfashionable and introduces the trouser. He's the king of trousers, yeah. Because the trouser is a simpler form of clothing. And also he loves a cravat. Do you know what he said of himself? He said, I, Brummel, put the modern man into pants, dark coat, white shirt and clean linen. I dare say that will be sufficient to secure my fame. And he's not wrong, is he? And actually that description, it's sad that he's using the
“裤子”（pants）这个词来指代长裤。所以他再次在燕尾服问题上和你站在一边。这在某些方面是一种非常朴素的装束。深色外套，白衬衫，干净的亚麻布。非常朴素。它进一步推动了朴素的标准，使一切都处于完美的平衡之中。所以他系领巾的方式，看起来像是一件艺术品。但重点是它不应该看起来像一件艺术品，这就是为什么人们想看它。但话虽如此，我读到他吹嘘说他每天花五个小时穿衣，并且用香槟擦靴子。
word pants to mean trousers. So again, he's with you on tuxedo clearly. That's quite a sober look in some ways. Dark coat, white shirt, clean linen. Very. It's pushing the standards of sobriety further so that everything is in a perfect balance. So his tying of a cravat, it comes to seem a work of art. But the point of it is that it shouldn't look like a work of art, which is why people want to see it. But that said, I read he boasted that it took him five hours a day to get dressed and that he polished his boots with champagne.
所以他的隐蔽性中仍然有一种显眼。哦，当然。绝对是这样。当然。我的意思是，这就是重点。它必须非常昂贵。它必须花费大量的时间。是的。
So there's still a conspicuousness to his inconspicuousness. Oh, of course. Absolutely. Of course. I mean, that's theuousness. Oh, of course. Absolutely. Of course. I mean, that's the whole point. It has to be very expensive. It has to take an enormous amount of time. Yeah.
但它不应该是炫耀或浮夸的。这就是它后来影响英国和美国人着装方式的关键方式。因为当然，他后来开始确立标准，是的，黑色长裤，当然还有白衬衫，在伦敦这样的工业城市和 19 世纪美国蓬勃发展的城市里，白衬衫真的很难保持洁白，所以保持它的清洁是地位的标志，绝对是这样。所以你有你的低调黑色，我们说过它们褪色非常容易，还有白色，真的很难。你基本上必须把衣服带到城外去洗。所以只有黑色和白色。但他那套衣服有趣的地方在于，它如何结合了
But it shouldn't be showy or flamboyant. That's the kind of the key way in which this then goes on to influence how people in Britain and in America will dress. Because of course, he then starts establishing the standard yes so black trousers also of course white shirts white shirts in an industrial city like London and the booming cities of the United States in the 19th century really difficult to keep a white shirt white so keeping it clean is a sign of status absolutely so you have your understated blacks which again you know we said how they fade very easily, and the white, really difficult. You have to take it basically outside the city to get laundered. So it's just black and white. But the interesting thing about his outfit though, is how it combines signs of
地位的标志和某种，平等主义是一个错误的词，但显然是长裤。利物浦伯爵在拿破仑战争结束时成为首相。他是第一位穿长裤的首相，不是吗，罗伯特·詹金森。长裤被认为比马裤和长筒袜更现代、更民主。是的，我想是这样。当然，它们是在模仿水手穿的衣服。皇家海军对长裤有很大的影响。所以博·布鲁梅尔启发的装束是地位标志（白衬衫，干净的白衬衫）与某种姿态（你知道，自由，我们
status with signs of a kind of, egalitarianism is the wrong word, but obviously trousers. Lord Liverpool becomes prime minister at the end of the Napoleonic Wars. He's the first Prime Minister, isn't he, Robert Jenkinson, to wear trousers. And trousers are seen as more modern, more democratic than breeches and stockings. Yeah, I think so. And of course, they are emulating what sailors wore. The Royal Navy is a big influence on trousers. So the Beau Brummel-inspired outfit is a nice combination of signs of status, the white shirt, the clean white shirt, with gestures towards a kind of, you know, liberty, we're
处于一个新时代，旧政权已经消失，所有这些东西）的完美结合。是的。我认为这种观念，我的意思是，民主是一个错误的词，但这种服装风格确实成为了体面的标志。博·布鲁梅尔是一个时尚引领者。但到了 1850 年代或 1860 年代，它绝对成为了为英国和美国资本主义车轮加油的庞大职员大军的制服。
in a new age, the Austrian regime is gone, all of that sort of stuff. Yeah. And I think that the idea that it is, I mean, democratic would be the wrong word, but that this is a style of clothing that becomes a marker of respectability. Beau Brummel is a fashion setter. But say by the, I don't know, the 1850s or the 1860s, it's absolutely become a uniform for the great armies of clerks who are oiling the wheels of British and American capitalism.
在一个新时代，奥地利政权已经不复存在，诸如此类。是的。我认为，说它具有民主色彩可能不太准确，但这种服装风格确实成为了受人尊敬的标志。博·布鲁梅尔是时尚的引领者。但到了19世纪50年代或60年代，它已经完全成为了那些为英美资本主义运转提供润滑的庞大职员队伍的制服。
And they're not actually wearing suits because the uniform, it's basically kind of black frock coats and the black and grey striped trousers. So basically the uniform of a valet, that's what it will become. Or someone going to a wedding. It's that kind of thing. Yeah. I was going to say a wedding. So interestingly, there's so many different gradations. So a frock coat, they really become standardised in the 1820s, 1830s. And they are from obviously court dress and military uniforms. I mean, a military coat looks like a frock coat, they really become standardized in the 1820s, 1830s. And they are from obviously court dress and military uniforms. I mean, a military coat looks like a frock coat, doesn't it? And then there's a more sporty version, which is the morning coat.
他们实际上并没有穿西装，因为这种制服基本上就是黑色礼服大衣配黑灰条纹长裤。所以，这基本上成了男仆的制服，或者参加婚礼的人穿的衣服。就是那种风格。是的，我正想说婚礼。有趣的是，它有许多不同的等级。礼服大衣在19世纪20年代和30年代真正实现了标准化。它们显然源自宫廷服饰和军装。我的意思是，军装大衣看起来就像礼服大衣，它们在19世纪20年代和30年代真正实现了标准化。它们显然源自宫廷服饰和军装。我的意思是，军装大衣看起来就像礼服大衣，不是吗？然后还有一种更运动的版本，就是晨礼服。
So that's what people often will hire to wear at a wedding. And actually, that's a coat that was designed so that you could ride in it. It's like a frock coat, but you can move more easily. And then obviously, the two other descendants of the dinner jacket and the lounge suit and the interesting thing about them is that they were both initially more informal than frock coats and morning coats yeah definitely we'll be coming to have the um the dinner jacket or tuxedo again we know exactly when that's invented we'll look at that in the second half yeah but the lounge suit which is effectively what most people wear today yeah that's something to wear in the country it's seen as the absolute
所以这就是人们经常租来在婚礼上穿的衣服。实际上，这种大衣的设计初衷是为了方便骑马。它就像礼服大衣，但你活动起来更方便。然后显然，另外两个后代是晚礼服和休闲西装，它们有趣的地方在于，最初它们都比礼服大衣和晨礼服更非正式。是的，我们肯定会谈到晚礼服或燕尾服，我们确切地知道它是何时发明的，我们会在下半部分讨论。是的，但休闲西装，也就是今天大多数人穿的衣服，那是穿在乡下的，它被视为绝对的
embodiment of the casual style it's sporty isn't it a lounge suit i mean hence the name lounge is like you'd wear it on holiday at a seaside hotel in the lounge because you weren't wearing your smart formal clothes and now of course people call that business suit, but it's not a business suit, Tom. Well, except that it kind of is because that dynamic between Bertie and Jeeves is running throughout the 19th century and into the 20th century. And I think the classic example of that is that brilliant comic novel, Diary of a Nobody, about the diary of a clerk who lives in Holloway, Mr. Pooter, and is very traditional. And he wears the frock coat and the grey striped trousers, the pinstripe trousers. And his son Lupin, who is very flash and does not wear that, wears a lounge suit. Oh, very common. Yeah. And Jeeves would not approve of him at all.
休闲风格的化身，它很运动，不是吗？休闲西装，我的意思是，顾名思义，“休闲”就像你在海边酒店度假时在休息室里穿的那样，因为你没穿那种考究的正式服装。当然，现在人们称之为商务西装，但它并不是商务西装，汤姆。嗯，除了它确实有点像，因为伯蒂和吉夫斯之间的那种动态贯穿了整个19世纪并延续到20世纪。我认为最经典的例子就是那部精彩的漫画小说《无名氏日记》，讲的是一位住在霍洛威的职员波特先生的日记，他非常传统。他穿着礼服大衣和灰条纹长裤，即细条纹长裤。而他的儿子卢平，非常浮夸，不穿那种衣服，而是穿休闲西装。哦，非常俗气。是的。吉夫斯根本不会认可他。
No. So you can see that although the limits for evolution within this male uniform are pretty circumscribed, there is nevertheless scope for evolution. And of course, that's turbocharged by the development of mass production. Oh, of course. Because up until this point, suits have been bespoke, they've been made to measure. But the development of mass production means that basically everyone, increasingly in the 20th century city, can wear a suit. So it's really interesting to look at the tipping point of change when the lounge suit
不。所以你可以看出，尽管这种男性制服的演变范围相当有限，但仍然有演变的空间。当然，这在大规模生产的发展下得到了极大的推动。哦，当然。因为在此之前，西装都是定制的，是量身定做的。但大规模生产的发展意味着，基本上每个人，在20世纪的城市里，越来越多的人可以穿上西装。所以，观察休闲西装的转折点是非常有趣的。
wins out. Because if you look at photographs of the Treaty of Versailles, there's some brilliant photographs of Clummelsoe, Lloyd George, Woodrow Wilson, and so on. They're wearing a great range of clothes. I mean, they're all wearing dark, in a vertical, suits. But one of them might be wearing a frock coat. One of them might be wearing a morning suit. One of them might be wearing a lounge suit.. One of them might be wearing a morning suit. One of them might be wearing a lounge suit.
它胜出了。因为如果你看凡尔赛条约的照片，有一些克莱蒙梭、劳合·乔治、伍德罗·威尔逊等人的精彩照片。他们穿着各种各样的衣服。我的意思是，他们都穿着深色的、垂直的西装。但其中一个人可能穿着礼服大衣。其中一个人可能穿着晨礼服。其中一个人可能穿着休闲西装。其中一个人可能穿着晨礼服。其中一个人可能穿着休闲西装。
I think the Italian guy is wearing a lounge suit. But if you fast forward 25 years, everybody would be in a lounge suit. I mean, I think Neville Chamberlain is probably the last British prime minister who would have worn a morning suit. You know, Anthony Eden, Harold Macmillan, they wear a lounge suit in the 1950s. Same with America. You can't imagine John F. Kennedy walking around in a frock coat. Don't you think that Chamberlain's dress explains a lot about his posthumous condemnation?
我想那个意大利人穿的是休闲西装。但如果你快进25年，每个人都会穿休闲西装。我的意思是，我认为内维尔·张伯伦可能是最后一位穿晨礼服的英国首相。你知道，安东尼·艾登、哈罗德·麦克米伦，他们在20世纪50年代都穿休闲西装。美国也是一样。你无法想象约翰·F·肯尼迪穿着礼服大衣走来走去。你不觉得张伯伦的着装在很大程度上解释了他死后受到的谴责吗？
Because he looks out of time. Yeah, his wing collar and his frock coat. Yeah. And interestingly, his predecessors, Tory's predecessors, Stanley Baldwin, had worn lounge suits. Chamberlain, he wanted to look reassuring, kind of rigorous, a reminder of greatness. That was his persona. And ironically, of course, it's now seen as an antiquated relic. I mean, one of the things I hadn't realised is why the lounge suit comes in
因为他看起来不合时宜。是的，他的翼领和礼服大衣。是的。有趣的是，他的前任，托利党的前任，斯坦利·鲍德温，穿的是休闲西装。张伯伦，他想让自己看起来令人安心，有点严谨，提醒人们过去的伟大。这就是他的人设。讽刺的是，当然，它现在被视为一种过时的遗迹。我的意思是，我没意识到的一件事是为什么休闲西装会流行起来
and lounge suits tend to be worn without waistcoats, is that the waistcoat is where you keep your fob watch. And the invention of the wristwatch means that you no longer need to do that. Oh, that's interesting. And also perhaps because places are warmer, better heated. Yes, that must be a reason as well. So you don't need three layers anymore. And of course, what also happens is that because the suit is the uniform of American capitalism. And because after the Second World War, American capitalism provides the model globally for business, the suit becomes an international uniform. And even the attempts to reject it, so the Nehru suit in India would be a classic. And of course, the Mao suit in China, both of them exist in the context of the suit. They are marked by what
而且休闲西装通常不穿背心，因为背心是用来放怀表的。而腕表的发明意味着你不再需要那样做了。哦，那很有趣。而且也许是因为地方更暖和，供暖更好了。是的，那一定也是一个原因。所以你不再需要三层衣服了。当然，还会发生什么呢，因为西装是美国资本主义的制服。而且因为二战后，美国资本主义为全球商业提供了模式，西装成为了一种国际制服。甚至那些试图拒绝它的尝试，比如印度的尼赫鲁装就是一个经典。当然，中国的中山装，它们都存在于西装的背景下。它们被它们所试图拒绝的东西所标记。
it is that they're trying to reject. So again, it's kind of like very modulated rejection of something, but you're still operating within the frameworks. Yeah. David Cameron era conservatives, they don't wear ties either. Yeah. Yeah. And I suppose that just as it was America that inherited the suit from Britain and then broadcast it around the world, spread it around the world. So now in Silicon Valley or wherever, the fashion for rejecting the suit, for going for hoodies and trainers and whatever, may well spell the end of the suit's centuries long primacy. That's a sad thought, Tom. That's one of the saddest things you've ever said on The Rest is History. I know. The barbarians are at the gates. But we don't want to finish this episode on such a sombre and distressing note. So let's take a break now. And when we come back, let's look at the great bastion of the traditional suit,
所以，这又是一种对某种东西非常温和的拒绝，但你仍然在框架内运作。是的。戴维·卡梅伦时代的保守党人，他们也不打领带。是的。是的。我想，正如美国从英国继承了西装并将其传播到世界各地一样，现在在硅谷或其他地方，拒绝西装、选择连帽衫和运动鞋等的时尚，很可能预示着西装长达几个世纪的统治地位的终结。那是个悲伤的想法，汤姆。这是你在《历史的其余部分》节目中说过的最悲伤的事情之一。我知道。野蛮人在门口。但我们不想以如此阴郁和令人沮丧的基调结束这一集。所以现在休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看传统西装的伟大堡垒，
which of course is Savile Row in London. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
当然就是伦敦的萨维尔街。等一下。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改拿铁订单太晚了吗？但有了KitchenAid的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了，因为你本可以在家自己做浓缩咖啡。现在就在KitchenAid.ca选购吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. welcome back to the rest is history with me Jeeves and Bertie Worcester Tom Holland who is talking us through the history of macaronis fops Dan Disbo Brummel the lounge suit the frock coat the tie and so much more and Tom as you said at the end of the first half, there is one place above all, a place that I think you and I both like very much, which is identified worldwide with the suit and with men's fashion. And that is, of course, Savile Row. So Savile Row, we moved quite briskly through the 18th century, but Savile Row in the West End of London is a product of the 18th century, isn't it? 1730s, that's right? Yeah, so that's when it gets built. And it's part of the Burlington
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，我是吉夫斯和伯蒂·伍斯特，汤姆·霍兰德，他正在为我们讲述通心粉、花花公子、丹·迪斯波·布鲁梅尔、休闲西装、礼服大衣、领带等等的历史。汤姆，正如你在上半场结束时所说，有一个地方高于一切，一个我认为你我都非常喜欢的地方，它在全世界被视为西装和男装时尚的代名词。那就是，当然，萨维尔街。所以萨维尔街，我们相当轻快地走过了18世纪，但伦敦西区的萨维尔街是18世纪的产物，不是吗？18世纪30年代，对吧？是的，那就是它建成的时候。它是伯灵顿庄园的一部分，
estate, which is developed over the course of the 18th century by the Earls of Burlington, who are Anglo-Irish. And Savile Row takes its name from the wife of the third Earl of Burlington, and she was called Lady Dorothy Sav saville right so that's where the name comes from would you like to know what uh savereau used to be yeah tell me it used to be the orchard of burlington house but when that all got developed in the mid-18th century sort of piccadilly park lane st james's i mean that's where gentlemen's clubs tend to be so it's the heart of the west end it's the heart of the West End. It's the heart of the fashionable part of London. And the tailors weren't initially on Savereau, because actually I read today, there's a brilliant book called The History of Savereau by a guy called, I think it's James
该庄园在18世纪由盎格鲁-爱尔兰裔的伯灵顿伯爵开发。萨维尔街的名字取自第三代伯灵顿伯爵的妻子，她叫多萝西·萨维尔夫人，对吧，所以名字就是这么来的。你想知道萨维尔街过去是什么吗？是的，告诉我。它过去是伯灵顿府的果园，但当这一切在18世纪中期开发时，比如皮卡迪利、公园巷、圣詹姆斯，我的意思是，那是绅士俱乐部聚集的地方，所以它是西区的中心。它是西区的中心。它是伦敦时尚区的中心。裁缝们最初并不在萨维尔街，因为实际上我今天读到，有一本很棒的书叫《萨维尔街的历史》，作者好像叫詹姆斯·谢泼德。
Shepard. And he says, actually, initially it was doctors. Oh, really? I thought it was military men. No, doctors first and the surrounding streets, yes, were military tailors. So Bond Street, Cork Street and so on, they had lots of military tailors. And interestingly, a lot of military tailors so bond street cork streets and so they had lots of military tailors and interestingly a lot of those tailors were jewish tom so there's always been a link between kind of east end jewish london and tailoring so producing tailors and that was the case even in the 18th century and then eventually they move into saville row after a few decades so lots of people may have heard of jeeeves and Hawks. So Thomas Hawks, he started actually in Soho in 1771, and he made military caps, and then caps for the aristocracy.
他说，实际上，最初是医生。哦，真的吗？我以为是军人。不，首先是医生，而周围的街道，是的，是军用裁缝。所以邦德街、科克街等等，有很多军用裁缝。有趣的是，很多军用裁缝都是犹太人，汤姆。所以东区的犹太伦敦和裁缝业之间一直有联系，所以生产裁缝，即使在18世纪也是如此。然后他们最终在几十年后搬进了萨维尔街。所以很多人可能听说过吉夫斯和霍克斯。所以托马斯·霍克斯，他实际上于1771年在苏豪区起家，他制作军帽，然后为贵族制作帽子。
And his caps were especially good because they were toughened so that a sabre couldn't cut through this cap that you would wear. I don't think you can get that today in Savile Row, can you? They might have them on show at Jeeves and Hawks. Jeeves and Hawks is still at number one Savile Row. I wish you could find out. Totally should. So already by, say, the Regency period, Savile Row is developing this kind of concentration of tailoring that enables it to thrive and to brand itself.
他的帽子特别好，因为它们经过加固，所以军刀无法切穿你戴的这种帽子。我想你今天在萨维尔街买不到那种东西了，对吧？他们可能在吉夫斯和霍克斯店里有展示。吉夫斯和霍克斯仍然在萨维尔街1号。我希望你能查清楚。绝对应该。所以到了摄政时期，萨维尔街已经形成了这种裁缝业的聚集，使它能够蓬勃发展并建立自己的品牌。
And these are the stamping grounds of Bo Brummel. So there's actually a statue of Bo Brummel, not in Savile Row, but on the other side of Piccadilly on German Street, which is where all the shirt makers are. So, you know, those traditions of high-end mail wear, they're centuries old. And that statue of Beau Brummel marks it. And I think that to go to one of them, I mean, even if you are just window shopping, I mean, it's kind of like going to Westminster Abbey to hear a psalm or something.
这些是博·布鲁梅尔的活动场所。实际上，博·布鲁梅尔的雕像不在萨维尔街，而是在皮卡迪利的另一边，在杰明街，那里全是衬衫制造商。所以，你知道，那些高端男装的传统已经有几个世纪的历史了。而那座博·布鲁梅尔的雕像标志着这一点。我认为去其中一家店，即使你只是橱窗购物，也就像去威斯敏斯特教堂听赞美诗一样。
You are participating in an aspect of London life that is living history, that kind of reaches back as a continuous thing for a very, very long time. And it establishes itself as the trendsetter, not just for London, not just for Britain, but for the world, because this is the heyday of the British Empire. And I think that London is to male tailoring what Paris is to female fashions. And I think that that explains the kind of the gendering of the two cities, because Paris in this period is always cast as female and London is always kind of staid and masculine and bewhiskered. And there's one staid masculine, well he's not that staid actually is he? No he's not staid at all. The weird thing is his public image is in some ways quite staid because he's often seen
你正在参与伦敦生活的一个方面，那是活生生的历史，它作为一种连续的事物延续了很长很长的时间。它确立了自己作为潮流引领者的地位，不仅是对伦敦，不仅是对英国，而是对全世界，因为这是大英帝国的全盛时期。我认为伦敦对男装裁缝业的意义，就像巴黎对女装时尚的意义一样。我认为这解释了这两个城市的性别化，因为这一时期的巴黎总是被塑造成女性化的，而伦敦总是显得沉稳、阳刚且留着胡须。有一个沉稳阳刚的，嗯，他其实没那么沉稳，不是吗？不，他一点也不沉稳。奇怪的是，他的公众形象在某些方面相当沉稳，因为他经常被看到
looking very grumpy in a gigantic sort of Inverness cape or something. And this is the future Edward VII, the son of Queen Victoria. Bertie. of Inverness Cape or something. And this is the future Edward VII, the son of Queen Victoria. Bertie. And he's often seen as the man more than anybody else who establishes the standards of male dress and in particular the suit. So the classic thing that lots of people will know is that he was very fat and he couldn't fasten his waistcoat. So he left the bottom button undone. And even now, it is very common, Tom, to do up the bottom button of your waistcoat. he left the bottom button undone and even now it is very common tom to do up the bottom button of your waistcoat is it not it is and uh he is the one who also inspires in this
看起来非常暴躁，穿着一件巨大的因弗内斯斗篷之类的东西。这就是未来的爱德华七世，维多利亚女王的儿子。伯蒂。他经常被视为比任何人都更能确立男性着装标准，特别是西装标准的人。所以很多人都知道的经典例子是，他很胖，扣不上背心。所以他把最下面的扣子解开了。即使是现在，汤姆，把背心最下面的扣子扣上也是非常普遍的，不是吗？是的，而且他也是在这个时期激发了晚礼服的发明，并普及了深色礼服大衣配白色背心，也就是那种企鹅装。我有一个关于晚礼服的事实，你会感兴趣的。晚礼服显然是受他启发的，因为在19世纪60年代，我想他在考斯的一次游艇度假中穿了一件吸烟装，这就是晚礼服的灵感来源。所以让我们记住，汤姆在考斯因为穿错了鞋而丢了脸，就像凯撒一样，是在考斯吗？是的，确实是。但有趣的是，威尔士亲王穿错了夹克。我们不应该叫它夹克。它是大衣。是的。每个人都模仿它。每个人都模仿它。所以这就是爱德华七世和凯撒的区别。而凯撒对此的怨恨解释了第一次世界大战，我们很快就会讲到。所以关于这一点，这件臭名昭著的大衣或夹克是由一位名叫亨利·普尔的裁缝制作的。所以这就是你关于英国帝国风格全球化的观点。亨利·普尔在19世纪40年代在萨维尔街开店。亨利·普尔为亚历山大二世沙皇、威廉一世皇帝制作衣服，但我相信不是第二位，这是他品味低下的标志。拿破仑三世，不是《历史的其余部分》的朋友，但却是《历史的其余部分》的伟大朋友，巴西的佩德罗二世让亨利·普尔为他制作衣服，这不是很棒吗？是的，而且不仅仅是正式服装，还有骑马装、运动装
period the invention of the dinner jacket and also the popularization of wearing a white waistcoat with dark dress coat so the kind of the penguin look i've got a fact about dinner jackets that would appeal to you the dinner jacket apparently is inspired by him because in the 1860s i think he wore a smoking jacket which was the inspiration for the dinner jacket at cows on a yachting holiday so let's just remember that tom shamed himself at cows by wearing the wrong shoes like the kaiser was it a cows uh yeah it was but what's interesting is that, you know, the Prince of Wales wears the wrong jacket. We shouldn't call it a jacket. It's a coat. Yeah. And everybody copies it. Everyone copies it. So that's the difference between Edward VII and the Kaiser. And it's the Kaiser's resentment of that that explains the First World
时期，晚礼服的发明以及深色礼服搭配白色背心的流行，也就是所谓的“企鹅装”。我有一个关于晚礼服的事实你可能会感兴趣，晚礼服显然是受他启发的，因为在19世纪60年代，我想他曾在考斯的一次游艇度假中穿过一件吸烟装，那正是晚礼服的灵感来源。所以我们要记住，汤姆曾在考斯因为穿错了鞋而让自己出丑，就像德皇一样，是在考斯吗？是的，确实是在那儿。但有趣的是，威尔士亲王穿错了外套——我们不该叫它外套，应该叫礼服——然后每个人都效仿他。每个人都效仿。这就是爱德华七世和德皇的区别。而德皇对此的怨恨正是第一次世界大战爆发的原因，我们很快就会讲到这一点。
War, which we'll be doing fairly soon. So on that, this notorious coat or jacket was made by a tailor called Henry Poole. So this is your point about the globalization of British imperial style. Henry Poole had set up in Savaree in the 1840s. Henry Poole made clothes for Tsar Alexander II, Kaiser Wilhelm I, but not, I believe, the second, which is a sign of his poor taste. Napoleon III, not a friend of the rest is history but a very great friend of the rest is history dom pedro the second of brazil had his clothes made by uh henry ball isn't that wonderful yeah and it's not just kind of formal wear so also riding habits sportswear
大战，我们很快就会讲到。说到这个，这件臭名昭著的礼服是由一位名叫亨利·普尔的裁缝制作的。这印证了你关于大英帝国风格全球化的观点。亨利·普尔在19世纪40年代在萨维尔街开店。亨利·普尔为亚历山大二世沙皇、威廉一世德皇制作过服装，但我认为他没有为威廉二世制作过，这说明威廉二世品味很差。拿破仑三世——虽然不是《历史的其余部分》的朋友，但却是《历史的其余部分》的忠实拥趸——巴西的佩德罗二世也穿亨利·普尔制作的衣服。这不是很棒吗？是的，而且这不仅仅是正式礼服，还包括骑马装和运动装。
and the classic tailor for that is huntsman oh yeah which is the model for kingsman people who've seen the film yeah that's where it was shot. Even today, Huntsman have quite a military riding look. They have the kind of roped shoulders and high arm holes and the stuff of a kind of a riding jacket. So in the changing room, there is a Crimean War period Hussars jacket, which you don't get in Marks and Spencer, that's to be said. And I guess the classic example of the reputation that Savile Row has is that Phileas Fogg, who is Jules Verne's globe-trotting adventurer in, around the world in, how many days is it? 80 days? He lives at 7 Savile Row. So it would be the perfect address for him. But Dominic,
而这方面的经典裁缝是亨茨曼。哦，是的，这就是《王牌特工》的原型，看过电影的人都知道，是的，那是在那里拍摄的。即使在今天，亨茨曼也有相当浓厚的军用骑马风格。他们有那种绳状肩部和高袖孔，以及骑马夹克的材质。所以在更衣室里，有一件克里米亚战争时期的轻骑兵夹克，你在玛莎百货是买不到的，这一点必须说明。我想萨维尔街声誉的经典例子是菲利亚斯·福格，也就是儒勒·凡尔纳笔下环游世界的冒险家，在《环游世界八十天》里，他住在萨维尔街7号。所以这对他是完美的地址。但多米尼克，
dark times for Savile Row with the emergence of mass production. So what is the future of high-end bespoke tailoring in an era of mass production? And I think that it's how record shops survive, isn't it? You put a premium on quirkiness, on quality, often on sheer expense, because a bespoke Savile Row suit is unbelievably expensive. But it's that kind of, it's vinyl against digital. Yeah. And it's the sort of sense of craftsmanship, but also I guess what you're buying. So you go to a Savile Row tailor and there's kind of the photos going back for decades. There's the royal warrants, there's all of that stuff. Often they'll have ledgers with the names of all famous customers. The point is you're buying the history. Yeah. So at Huntsman, they provided the funerary wear for Queen Victoria's funeral,
随着大规模生产的出现，萨维尔街迎来了黑暗时期。那么，在大规模生产时代，高端定制裁缝的未来是什么？我认为这就像唱片店生存的方式，不是吗？你把重点放在古怪、质量上，通常是纯粹的昂贵，因为一套萨维尔街定制西装贵得令人难以置信。但这就像黑胶唱片对抗数字音乐。是的。这是一种工艺感，但我猜你买的也是那种感觉。所以你去萨维尔街的裁缝店，那里有几十年的照片。有皇家认证，有所有那些东西。他们通常会有记录所有著名顾客名字的账本。重点是你买的是历史。是的。所以在亨茨曼，他们为维多利亚女王的葬礼提供了丧服，
and you can see all the details of that in their ledgers. So it's amazing. I mean, it's kind of real, real history, vivid history. But I thought it would be interesting to look at two tailors that set up in the 20th century, the only two who've really established themselves, to see how they coped, you know, how they were able to establish themselves in the era of mass production. So the first of these is Anderson and Shepherd. That's a very great tailor, Tom. Which is founded in 1906. So relative to most of the other houses on Savile Row, very much a latecomer. And it's an absolute icon of british tailoring but a bit like the tailors who were setting up in the 18th century that you talked about it's founded by two people from
你可以在他们的账本中看到所有细节。所以这太神奇了。我的意思是，这是真正的、真正的历史，生动的历史。但我认为看看两家在20世纪成立的裁缝店会很有趣，这是仅有的两家真正站稳脚跟的裁缝店，看看他们是如何应对的，你知道，他们是如何在大规模生产时代站稳脚跟的。所以第一家是安德森和谢泼德。那是一家非常伟大的裁缝店，汤姆。它成立于1906年。所以相对于萨维尔街上的大多数其他老店，它是一个后来者。它是英国裁缝业的绝对偶像，但有点像你谈到的18世纪成立的裁缝店，它是由两个外国人创立的，
abroad so one of them is a swede per gustav anderson so hence anderson and shepherd and the other one is a dutchman frederica schalter and they team up with a trouser cutter called sydney shepherd yeah so hence anderson and shepherd and it is very very i mean it sounds sounds odd to say that savile row taylor can be self-consciously revolutionary yeah but it is because they repudiate the military character of the traditional savile row suit the kind that you get at huntsman and they patent what comes to be called the english drape. And a drape, of course, Dominic, is how the jacket hangs from the shoulders. And it provides a kind of a softer look. Shoulders aren't padded, lots of room in the sleeves so you can kind of move your arms up and down. Very flattering. And I think
所以其中一个是瑞典人佩尔·古斯塔夫·安德森，所以叫安德森和谢泼德，另一个是荷兰人弗雷德里卡·沙尔特。他们与一位名叫悉尼·谢泼德的裤子裁剪师合作。是的，所以叫安德森和谢泼德。这非常非常，我的意思是，说萨维尔街的裁缝可以有意识地进行革命听起来很奇怪，但确实如此，因为他们摒弃了传统萨维尔街西装的军事特征，也就是你在亨茨曼那种店里买到的那种，他们申请了后来被称为“英式垂坠”的专利。多米尼克，垂坠当然是指夹克从肩膀垂下的方式。它提供了一种更柔和的外观。肩膀没有垫肩，袖子空间很大，所以你可以轻松地上下活动手臂。非常修身。我认为
that this is why it becomes very, very popular with people from show business backgrounds. Yeah. Even though Schulte himself was very snobbish about them. He didn't really approve of show business people. And it operates a little bit like a private club. So you don't absolutely have to have a recommendation, but it definitely helps. So Noel Coward, who's a very early convert, I mean, he loves Anderson and Shepard suits. He vouches for Laurence Olivier, who's a very early convert, I mean, he loves Anderson and Shepard suits.
这就是为什么它在演艺界人士中变得非常非常受欢迎。是的。尽管沙尔特本人对他们非常势利。他并不真正认可演艺界人士。它的运作方式有点像私人俱乐部。所以你不一定非要有推荐，但有推荐肯定有帮助。所以诺埃尔·考沃德，他是一个非常早期的皈依者，我的意思是，他喜欢安德森和谢泼德的西装。他为劳伦斯·奥利弗担保，他是一个非常早期的皈依者，我的意思是，他喜欢安德森和谢泼德的西装。
He vouches for Laurence Olivier, who then becomes a devotee. And brilliantly, Douglas Fairbanks Jr., he vouches for Marlena Dietrich. Oh, very good. You know, the definitive female wearer of a masculine suit. Yeah. Very, very famous for it. But the point of the drape and the informality. So, I mean, informality is a weird thing to say about a several rotator,
他为劳伦斯·奥利弗担保，后者后来成为了忠实拥趸。精彩的是，小道格拉斯·范朋克为玛琳·黛德丽担保。哦，非常好。你知道，男性西装的终极女性穿着者。是的。非常非常出名。但垂坠和非正式的意义在于。所以，我的意思是，对于萨维尔街的裁缝店来说，非正式是一个奇怪的说法，
but it's less rigid than a sort of military huntsman type car. That's structured, I suppose. Is that you can move in it, of course. You can move more freely. And so the classic example of this Anderson Shepard is Fred Astaire. That's right, isn't it? I mean, Fred Astaire, people always say, is one of the great wearers of a suit in all history.
但它比那种军事化的亨茨曼式夹克不那么僵硬。我想那是结构化的。就是你可以穿着它活动，当然。你可以更自由地活动。所以安德森和谢泼德的经典例子是弗雷德·阿斯泰尔。没错，不是吗？我的意思是，人们总是说弗雷德·阿斯泰尔是历史上最伟大的西装穿着者之一。
Yes, that's right. And so the story is that he comes and they will roll up the carpet and he will kind of tap dance and pirouette. I love that. To see whether he can wear it adequately. But isn't it right as well though, so you talked about being revolutionary, but of course in one way it's not revolutionary at all because just like the previous generation of Savoy-Taylor, say Henry Poole's and whatnot, it relies on royal patronage. And in this case, it's Edward VIII. So another Prince of Wales. So it's before he becomes king.
是的，没错。所以故事是这样的，他来了，他们会卷起地毯，他会跳踢踏舞和旋转。我喜欢这个。看看他是否能穿得合适。但话说回来，你谈到了革命性，但当然在某种程度上它一点也不革命，因为就像前几代萨维尔街裁缝一样，比如亨利·普尔等等，它依赖于皇室的惠顾。在这种情况下，是爱德华八世。所以又是另一位威尔士亲王。所以这是在他成为国王之前。
His father, George V, I mean, he's very old-fashioned, isn't he? He, in fact, has very firm views about the creasing of his trousers. So he creases them at the sides and despises men who don't. Whereas his son, the future Edward VIII, is the first member of the royal family to wear trousers that contain a zip. That's where it went wrong for Britain. And I think that the fact that he will go on to marry an American and abdicate, I mean, I think that that future is ripped there in the adoption of the zip.
他的父亲乔治五世，我的意思是，他非常老派，不是吗？事实上，他对裤子的折痕有非常坚定的看法。所以他把折痕压在侧面，鄙视不这样做的人。而他的儿子，未来的爱德华八世，是皇室中第一个穿带拉链裤子的人。这就是英国走错路的地方。我认为他后来娶了一位美国人并退位的事实，我的意思是，我认为那个未来在采用拉链时就已经注定了。
Shocking, isn't it? I mean, terrible moments for Britain. Yeah, terrible. I bet Prince Harry's a zip man. Probably. Well, of course, his father, the current king, Charles, massive, massive fan of Anderson and Shepard. So he gets introduced to it by Diana in 1983. And he apparently appears in the ledger as Charles Smith. Although it is important to point out that this is hearsay because the secrets of the ledger book are very rigorously kept. And he has an Anderson and Shepard coat that he still wears that he's had since 1983. But the best thing about Prince Charles as he was
令人震惊，不是吗？我的意思是，对英国来说是可怕的时刻。是的，可怕。我敢打赌哈里王子是个拉链男。可能吧。好吧，当然，他的父亲，现任国王查尔斯，是安德森和谢泼德的超级超级粉丝。所以他在1983年被戴安娜介绍到那里。他显然在账本上以查尔斯·史密斯的名字出现。尽管必须指出这只是道听途说，因为账本的秘密被非常严格地保守着。他有一件安德森和谢泼德的大衣，他从1983年起就一直穿着。但关于查尔斯王子最好的事情是，
is that there's an intersection with perhaps the most famous apprentice at anderson shepherd who's alexander mcqueen the enfant terrible of british tailoring so he was there and he boasted in the 1990s that during his apprenticeship there so when you're a fitter you you write in chalk don't you on the fabric yeah and he said that they were making a coat for prince charles and he was working on it and he scrawled in chalk i am am a C-U-N-T. Oh, Tom. But am I not right in saying that, I mean, I know this is my pointed role in historiography generally, is to point out that things aren't true.
有一个人与安德森和谢泼德最著名的学徒有交集，那就是亚历山大·麦昆，英国裁缝界的“坏孩子”。所以他在那里，他在20世纪90年代吹嘘说，在他当学徒期间，也就是当你做试衣员时，你在布料上用粉笔写字，对吧？他说他们当时正在为查尔斯王子做一件大衣，他正在上面工作，他用粉笔潦草地写下了“我是一个混蛋”。哦，汤姆。但我说得不对吗，我的意思是，我知道这是我在史学中通常的尖锐角色，指出事情不是真的。
This is in fact not true. And that the chief cutter at Anderson Shepard said there is no way that this would have been possible. And in fact, we checked when we heard this story. We recalled the coat and checked and it wasn't true at all. Yeah. So a good story that turns out not to be true. And there, I think, essentially is what the rest of history is all about. But I mean, it's interesting.
这事实上不是真的。安德森和谢泼德的首席裁剪师说，这根本不可能。事实上，我们听到这个故事时核实了一下。我们调出了那件大衣并检查了，根本不是真的。是的。所以一个好故事结果不是真的。我想，这本质上就是《历史的其余部分》的全部意义所在。但我的意思是，这很有趣。
So, of course, Anderson and Shepard maintains the style that kind of made it famous. Yeah. I mean, it hasn't evolved in response to kind of trends of the time and that's why it's a timeless classic right so calvin klein's big fan tom ford big fan i get the impression tom that if the rest is history had an official tailor you would like it to be anderson shepherd am i right yeah i think i would oh that's nice although there is another tailor who sets up in the 60s quite like one one of the suits from them, but they're no longer around. But Alexander McQueen's presence on Savile Row is a reminder that British tailoring, high-end British tailoring, is capable of generating a kind of, I use inverted commas, revolutionary trends.
所以，当然，安德森和谢泼德保持了使它成名的风格。是的。我的意思是，它没有随着时代的潮流而演变，这就是为什么它是一个永恒的经典，对吧？所以卡尔文·克莱恩是超级粉丝，汤姆·福特也是超级粉丝。我有一种感觉，汤姆，如果《历史的其余部分》有官方裁缝，你会希望是安德森和谢泼德，我说的对吗？是的，我想我会的。哦，那很好。尽管还有另一位在60年代成立的裁缝店，我很喜欢他们的一套西装，但他们已经不在了。但亚历山大·麦昆在萨维尔街的存在提醒我们，英国裁缝业，高端英国裁缝业，有能力产生一种，我用引号，革命性的趋势。
A frisson. And the 1960s is a real period of crisis for Savile Row. It's seen as being absolutely kind of woefully fusty. So Cecil Beaton in Vogue in the 60s wrote, it is ridiculous that they go on turning out clothes that make men look like characters from PG Woodhouse. I'm terribly bored with their styling, so behind the times, they really should pay attention to the fashion produced by the young mods. And of course, Savile Row becomes the headquarters of the Beatles, of Apple Corps. And that is where they have their last concert.
一种震颤。20世纪60年代是萨维尔街真正的危机时期。它被认为是非常令人沮丧的守旧。所以塞西尔·比顿在60年代的《Vogue》中写道，他们继续生产让男人看起来像PG伍德豪斯笔下人物的衣服是荒谬的。我对他们的造型感到非常厌烦，太落后于时代了，他们真的应该关注年轻摩登族生产的时尚。当然，萨维尔街成为了披头士乐队、苹果公司的总部。那就是他们最后一场音乐会的地方。
On the roof, yeah. Yeah, on the 30th of January 1969, which features at the end of Get Back, the Peter Jackson film that came out last year. Two weeks after that concert, the tailor who makes three of the suits that the Beatles are wearing on the cover of Abbey Road. So only George Harrison, who's in denim, is not wearing a suit made by this guy. He opens a shop on Savile Row, and this is called Nutter's of Savile Row. It's a great name. And it's named after Tommy Nutter, who is the kind of the frontman for it, who's an absolutely classic 60s figure. Yeah. the frontman for it, who's an absolutely classic 60s figure. So he's working class, son of a
在屋顶上，是的。是的，1969年1月30日，这在去年上映的彼得·杰克逊的电影《回归》的结尾有体现。在那场音乐会两周后，制作披头士在《艾比路》封面上穿的三套西装的裁缝。所以只有乔治·哈里森，他穿着牛仔布，没有穿这个家伙做的西装。他在萨维尔街开了一家店，这叫“纳特的萨维尔街”。这是一个很棒的名字。它以汤米·纳特命名，他是那种门面人物，是一个绝对经典的60年代人物。是的。他是门面人物，是一个绝对经典的60年代人物。所以他是工人阶级，是一个水管工的儿子，
plumber, hates his father, who he sees as kind of oppressive, domineering, goes to work as a tea boy in the civil service. Then he sees an ad, Savile Row tailors have vacancy for youth to learn trimming, packing and general shop duties. He goes and answers the ad, gets the job, becomes completely obsessed by tailoring. He studies at the Taylor and Cutter Academy on Gerrard Street doing night classes. He's actually not very good at it. So Lance Richardson, who wrote a brilliant book on this, House of Nutter, the rebel tailor of Savile Row, says if a cutter can be likened to a brain surgeon, the Academy taught Tommy just enough to be a nurse. But it doesn't really matter because he's very, very groovy. Right. And very, very good looking. And he has good contacts.
讨厌他的父亲，他认为父亲是那种压迫性的、专横的人，去公务员部门当了茶水员。然后他看到一个广告，萨维尔街裁缝店招聘年轻人学习修剪、包装和一般商店职责。他去应聘，得到了这份工作，变得完全痴迷于裁缝。他在杰拉德街的裁缝和裁剪学院上夜校。他其实不太擅长。所以兰斯·理查森，他写了一本关于这个的精彩书籍《纳特之家，萨维尔街的叛逆裁缝》，说如果裁剪师可以比作脑外科医生，学院只教了汤米足够当护士的知识。但这并不重要，因为他非常非常时髦。对。而且非常非常帅。而且他有很好的人脉。
So he's gay and he goes to a party at Brian Epstein's, the manager of the Beatles, where he meets Peter Brown, who is Brian Epstein's assistant. Yeah. Ends up being a big cheese in apple core. Yeah. So when Brian Epstein dies, basically Peter Brown takes over the kind of the gopher role and he's name checked in the Ballad of John and Yoko as the man who arranges for John and Yoko to get married in Gibraltar near Spain.
所以他是同性恋，他去参加了披头士经理布莱恩·爱普斯坦的派对，在那里他遇到了彼得·布朗，他是布莱恩·爱普斯坦的助手。是的。最终成为了苹果公司的大人物。是的。所以当布莱恩·爱普斯坦去世时，基本上彼得·布朗接管了那种跑腿的角色，他在《约翰和洋子的歌谣》中被点名，作为安排约翰和洋子在西班牙附近的直布罗陀结婚的人。
And this is why Tommy Nutter starts mixing with 60s pop royalty. So he's one of the first people to listen to Hey Jude. And, you know, he says he thinks it's rubbish as a joke. Great banter. Great banter. And his brother also, John, is a fashion photographer. So he takes the photos for John and Yoko's wedding. And Peter Brown teams up with Cilla Black, later TV presenter. And they basically fund Nutters of Savile Row. And it's
这就是为什么汤米·纳特开始与60年代的流行音乐皇室成员混在一起。所以他是第一批听《Hey Jude》的人之一。而且，你知道，他开玩笑说他觉得那是垃圾。很棒的玩笑。很棒的玩笑。他的兄弟约翰也是一位时尚摄影师。所以他为约翰和洋子的婚礼拍了照片。彼得·布朗与后来成为电视主持人的西拉·布莱克合作。他们基本上资助了纳特的萨维尔街。而且它
an absolutely massive success. And that's partly because Tommy Nutter has this tremendous charisma and taste. You know, he's very innovative in his designs, but also because he has this partner, a guy called Edward Sexton, who's an absolutely old school master of tailoring. And they set up this shop and it helps to modernize Savile Row because it's the first Savile Row shop that has display windows, open windows. Yeah. So Lance Richardson writes about it, that the first Nutter's look represented a culmination of everything mod, smashing, subversive, continental, American, queer and camp, combined with a keen fidelity to old school Savile Row craftsmanship. So it's groovy and it's traditional. And it's not surprising that Mick Jagger loves it. Bianca Jagger loves it.
是一个绝对巨大的成功。这部分是因为汤米·纳特拥有这种巨大的魅力和品味。你知道，他在设计上非常有创新，但也因为他有一个合伙人，一个叫爱德华·塞克斯顿的家伙，他是一位绝对老派的裁缝大师。他们开了这家店，它有助于萨维尔街的现代化，因为它是第一家有展示橱窗、开放式橱窗的萨维尔街商店。是的。所以兰斯·理查森写道，第一个纳特风格代表了所有摩登、粉碎、颠覆、大陆、美国、酷儿和营地风格的顶点，结合了对老派萨维尔街工艺的敏锐忠诚。所以它既时髦又传统。米克·贾格尔喜欢它，比安卡·贾格尔喜欢它，这并不奇怪。
Elton John. Elton John loves it. But also the Duke of Bedford and Lord Montague. Yeah. So, you know, all kinds of nobility so when you look at the photos of those suits from the 60s and 70s they are very cool they've imbibed that 60s spirit of kind of victoriana haven't they so they're quite long coats they're sort of quite victorian looking sometimes gigantic lapels yeah and that look that sort of flamboyance is enduring. So in 1989, when Tim Burton makes his Batman film
埃尔顿·约翰。埃尔顿·约翰喜欢它。还有贝德福德公爵和蒙塔古勋爵。是的。所以，你知道，各种各样的贵族。所以当你看到60年代和70年代那些西装的照片时，它们非常酷，它们吸收了那种60年代维多利亚时代的精神，不是吗？所以它们是相当长的大衣，它们看起来有时非常维多利亚风格，巨大的翻领。是的，那种外观，那种浮夸是持久的。所以1989年，当蒂姆·伯顿制作他的《蝙蝠侠》电影时，
with Jack Nicholson's The Joker, I think it's Tommy Nutter who designs the Joker's suit. Because by that point, Tommy Nutter and Edward Sexton have basically split up, a bit like the Beatles. And Edward Sexton said, Tommy was fantastic. Nobody could touch him, socialising and bringing in the right type of clients. I've got nothing but love and affection for him as a person and a creative figure. But as a businessman, he was fucking useless. So very sad.
杰克·尼科尔森饰演的小丑，我想是汤米·纳特设计了小丑的西装。因为到那时，汤米·纳特和爱德华·塞克斯顿基本上分道扬镳了，有点像披头士。爱德华·塞克斯顿说，汤米太棒了。没有人能比得上他，在社交和引入合适的客户方面。作为一个人和一个创意人物，我对他只有爱和感情。但作为一个商人，他他妈的一无是处。所以非常悲伤。
Is that how he talked? Yeah, it is. I listened to him. That's how he talked. Brilliant. And so basically Edward Sexton realises that Tommy is an absolute liability because he doesn't understand money he's just spending it
他是那样说话的吗？是的，确实。我听过他说话。他就是那样说话的。精彩。所以基本上爱德华·塞克斯顿意识到汤米是一个绝对的累赘，因为他不了解钱，他只是在挥霍它，
and he buys him out and Tommy goes on to design as you said the Joker suit and all that kind of thing then he dies in 1992 of AIDS but Edward Sexton
他买下了他的股份，汤米继续设计你所说的小丑西装等等，然后他在1992年死于艾滋病，但爱德华·塞克斯顿
is still going I mean he died last year I think he did Harry Styles' pink suit yeah the famous pink suit so I'm going to tell you
还在继续。我的意思是，他去年去世了，我想他做了哈里·斯泰尔斯的粉色西装，是的，那件著名的粉色西装。所以我现在要告诉你
a fact now about Tommy Sexton, Tom, that will please you enormously. On Saturday, we walked down Savile Row because I knew this podcast was coming and wanted to get inspiration. And also my wife wanted to visit a shop called The Deck, which is the first tailors on Savile Row, staffed, run by, and aimed at women. So we went to the deck, lovely, very nice. And then we went next door because we were just passing and we saw these jackets in the window. And I was like, oh, they're lovely jackets. Let's just go in there. And I hadn't looked at what the shop was called. We went in, it was Edward Sexton, Tom. My God, living history. And I said to this guy, I like this jacket, whatever. And when he heard me talking, he just stared at me in stupefaction. And then he said, the rest is history.
一个关于汤米·塞克斯顿的事实，汤姆，这会让你非常高兴。周六，我们走在萨维尔街，因为我知道这个播客要来了，想获得灵感。而且我妻子想去一家叫“甲板”的店，这是萨维尔街第一家由女性配备、经营并针对女性的裁缝店。所以我们去了甲板，很可爱，非常好。然后我们去了隔壁，因为我们正好路过，我们看到了橱窗里的这些夹克。我就说，哦，它们是可爱的夹克。我们进去吧。我没看那家店叫什么名字。我们进去了，那是爱德华·塞克斯顿，汤姆。天哪，活生生的历史。我对这个家伙说，我喜欢这件夹克，什么的。当他听到我说话时，他只是目瞪口呆地盯着我。然后他说，历史的其余部分。
And I said, yeah. He said, so weird. I was listening to Lord Byron this morning. Oh, that's brilliant. So there you go. I thought you'd enjoy that. So that's Alex Lamb from Edward Sexton, who is a listener to the rest is history. Okay.
我说，是的。他说，太奇怪了。我今天早上还在听拜伦勋爵。哦，那太棒了。所以给你。我想你会喜欢的。那是来自爱德华·塞克斯顿的亚历克斯·兰姆，他是《历史的其余部分》的听众。好的。
Well, that's good. You're giving him a shout out. I would like to end this by giving a shout out to Will and Marie, who run Old Town, who are brilliant tailors. They're not on Savile Row, they're on Holt on the north coast of Norfolk. But they're about to retire and I've got loads of their stuff and I've frantically ordered three more suits. Three suits? How many suits do you need? Well, because they're now retiring. Yeah. So, you know, I need to get in there.
好吧，那很好。你在给他大声疾呼。我想以向威尔和玛丽致敬来结束这一集，他们经营着“老城”，他们是出色的裁缝。他们不在萨维尔街，他们在诺福克北海岸的霍尔特。但他们快要退休了，我买了很多他们的东西，我疯狂地又订了三套西装。三套西装？你需要多少套西装？嗯，因为他们现在要退休了。是的。所以，你知道，我需要进去。
Anyway, I know that they're both listeners to the rest of history. So, Will and Marie, thank you so much for everything you've done. All your fans love you. And sorry for that incredible self-indulgence. I hope that everyone else will forgive me. I think everyone will forgive that. Just as we end the podcast. So, the future of the suit.
总之，我知道他们俩都是《历史的其余部分》的听众。所以，威尔和玛丽，非常感谢你们所做的一切。你们所有的粉丝都爱你们。抱歉那次令人难以置信的自我放纵。我希望其他人会原谅我。我想每个人都会原谅的。就在我们结束播客时。所以，西装的未来。
There's a brilliant guy on Twitter called Derek Guy. He loves the King of Spain. Yes, he does, doesn't he? Yeah. He's always posting stuff about the King of Spain and comparing him with, I don't know, Andrew Tate or Jordan Peterson or somebody and saying, look how brilliant the King of Spain is. Wasn't there was some photo of him at Wimbledon or something?
推特上有一个很棒的家伙叫德里克·盖伊。他喜欢西班牙国王。是的，他喜欢，不是吗？是的。他总是发布关于西班牙国王的东西，并把他和，我不知道，安德鲁·泰特或乔丹·彼得森或某人进行比较，说，看看西班牙国王有多棒。他不是在温布尔登还是什么地方有一张照片吗？
There was, exactly. Looking very stylish. So this guy on Twitter is very up on the King of Spain and traditional tailoring and very down on Daniel Craig's pink suits, which are too tight and all that kind of thing. And yeah, everybody loves that. And it's a great thing. It's funny and all this sort of stuff, but there's something that's obviously very self-consciously retro about it. So in other words, the suit lies in the past. And my question to you is now that you've done all this research on the history of suits, a sentence I never thought i'd say where is it going do you think it will endure because it's the uniform attached to a particular cast and it has a status and a prestige attached to it or do you think it
确实，正是如此。看起来非常时尚。所以推特上的这个家伙非常了解西班牙国王和传统裁缝，非常看不起丹尼尔·克雷格的粉色西装，它们太紧了等等。是的，每个人都喜欢那个。这是一件很棒的事情。它很有趣，所有这些东西，但显然有一种非常有意识的复古感。所以换句话说，西装属于过去。我现在问你，既然你做了所有关于西装历史的研究，我从未想过我会说的一句话，你认为它会走向何方？你认为它会持续下去吗，因为它是一种附属于特定阶层的制服，并且附带了一种地位和声望，还是你认为它
is all doomed and we are all going to be wearing hoodies and jeans in 40 years i think it will endear because i think that probably in business, and I speak as someone who's never really had a job, but I get the sense that if you're in business, there are occasions where you need to look smart and convey a sense that you're being serious. So even if you're a tech bro, there may come the point where you've got to go to Davos or something and give a talk about AI. And probably then you need an item of clothing that will signify that you're serious. And I think it's interesting how it does seem to me that women still struggle with that. So the female suit kind of slightly conveys receptionist now, doesn't it?
一切都注定要完蛋，四十年后我们都要穿连帽衫和牛仔裤吗？我认为西装会延续下去，因为我觉得在商业领域——我作为一个从未真正打过工的人这么说——但我有一种感觉，如果你在商界，总有些场合需要看起来精明干练，传达出一种你很严肃的感觉。所以即使你是科技圈的精英，也总会遇到要去达沃斯之类的地方谈论人工智能的时候。那时候你可能就需要一件能表明你很严肃的服装。而且我觉得很有趣的是，女性似乎仍然在这一点上感到挣扎。现在的女性西装穿起来有点像前台接待员，不是吗？
There's a bit of a Hillary Clinton side to the female suit, isn't it? The pant suit. The pant suit. And that's become very dated yeah which is why i think for men the suit probably will endure because it kind of gets you out of that problem do you know tom that's why i think it endures it's a kind of uniform and uniforms can be quite useful totally i like wearing a suit because i like to be inconspicuous and because you know i can just be really bland and um i don't have any taste so i can escape being judged i think it's the sartorial equivalent of businessman's english i mean even if you know britain's obviously declined but america declines relative to the rest of the world english is simply too useful to fade and likewise with the suit but equally
女性西装总带点希拉里·克林顿的感觉，不是吗？那种裤装。裤装。那已经变得非常过时了。是的，所以我认为对于男性来说，西装可能会延续下去，因为它能帮你摆脱那种困境。汤姆，你知道吗，这就是我认为它能延续的原因，它是一种制服，而制服有时非常有用。完全同意，我喜欢穿西装，因为我喜欢不引人注目，而且你知道，我可以表现得非常平庸，嗯，我没什么品味，所以我可以避免被评头论足。我认为这相当于商务英语的服装版，我的意思是，即使英国显然衰落了，美国相对于世界其他地区也在衰落，但英语实在太有用了，不会消失，西装也是如此，但同样地，
just as businessman's english is not something that you would write a book or a poem with so also i imagine that if the suit continues as the kind of default uniform there will be scope for savile row or for designers like tom ford or george romani or whatever that can refine it yeah so i would guess it probably is going to India, despite the best that Silicon Valley can throw at it. All right. On that heartening note, Tom, I think we should draw a close over this.
就像你不会用商务英语来写书或写诗一样，我也想象如果西装继续作为一种默认的制服，萨维尔街或像汤姆·福特、乔治·阿玛尼之类的设计师仍然有发挥空间来改良它。是的，所以我猜它很可能会流传下去，尽管硅谷尽其所能想要淘汰它。好吧，带着这个令人振奋的结论，汤姆，我想我们应该结束这个话题了。
That was absolutely fascinating. A tour de force. We haven't had a tour de force for a little while and the rest is history. So it's nice to have one again. Oh, thank you. I found it unexpectedly interesting. Yeah, really good. And if any of the establishments mentioned in this podcast
这真是太迷人了。简直是一场精彩的演说。我们已经有一段时间没有这种精彩的演说了，而剩下的就是历史了。所以能再听到一次真是太好了。哦，谢谢。我发现它出乎意料地有趣。是的，真的很好。如果本播客中提到的任何机构
wish to express their appreciation, I wouldn't encourage that kind of behavior. If they do, that's great. Goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
想要表达他们的感谢，我不鼓励这种行为。如果他们真的这么做了，那也很好。再见。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即历史》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。